[Music]
ever notice how tv commercials for big
banks go really hard on the schmaltz
loving families cute babies sweet old
retired people micro pigs on leashes
it's almost as if they're trying to
distract us from something oh you mean
like how in 2016 wells fargo admitted to
creating 3.5 million fake accounts for
customers to collect extra fees and
charged over 570 000 people for auto
insurance they didn't need resulting in
over 20 000 customers going into default
and then there's the now infamous
practices of citibank lehman brothers
aig and other wall street giants of
bundling toxic junk assets and
repackaging them as aaa super safe
investments which led to a near collapse
of the international money system that
ordinary people are still hurting from
and most americans feel that big banks
are rewarded rather than punished for
risky and predatory behavior bank of
america received tens of billions in
bailout funds in 2009 only to turn
around the very next year and pay 35
billion in executive bonuses not
surprisingly our trust in these
institutions is low a recent gallup poll
showed that only 27 percent of americans
have confidence in banks but this is not
a new phenomenon 14th century poet dante
placed moneylenders in the seventh
circle of hell below violent murderers
and blasphemers so being suspicious of
big banks is nothing new but what can
you do you've got to stash your cash
somewhere and who can get through life
without ever taking a loan or using a
credit card thankfully you do have
options alternatives to big banks have
been around for a while and if you
haven't looked into them yet it might be
time
[Music]
one good alternative is a local
community bank their fees and charges
can be lower than national chains and
you can be pretty sure they won't use
your money for risky bets or wall street
gambles instead they tend to make
investments in the immediate region
helping to develop projects and
businesses that create jobs and improve
spaces in your hometown there are over
52 000 community bank locations
nationwide and you can find ones in your
area by checking out the icba's website
then there are banks that don't rely on
physical locations online banks like
simple and chime usually have lower fees
partly due to having no brick and mortar
expenses they also tend to have no
account minimums don't charge overdraft
fees and atms are fee free at tens of
thousands of locations both local banks
and online base banks still typically
offer fdic protection on up to 250 000
worth of deposits per person and account
type so for most people they are just as
secure as the big national chains you
can also choose to ditch banks
altogether and open up an account at a
credit union credit unions allow you to
make deposits and withdrawals take out
loans and credit cards and enjoy most
other services you might expect from a
bank but unlike banks credit unions are
all non-profit entities any profits made
by the credit union are returned to you
in the form of reduced fees higher
savings rates and better loan terms this
is because credit unions technically
don't have customers they have members
everyone who keeps their money at a
credit union is seen as a part owner of
the institution and they usually all
share a common bond perhaps they all
live in a particular geographic location
work in the same industry or are all
alumni of the same university one
member's deposits end up becoming an
auto or business loan for another member
teamwork credit unions offer fdic-like
protection through the ncusif and most
credit unions are part of a national
shared branch network which allows you
to utilize thousands of other credit
unions just like they were your own so
depending on your credit union you could
have access to even more atms and
branches than with a big national bank
maybe this all sounds great to you and
you're ready to say sayonara to your big
bank but there are a few drawbacks to
consider before making the switch
because of their size and scope big
banks are better at international
banking and lending making a withdrawal
from abroad or getting a loan in another
country can be a tall order for many
local banks and credit unions so if you
do a lot of traveling or have a
cross-border business sticking with your
big bank might make your life easier
also smaller banks and credit unions
usually can't compete with the big
bank's digital offerings so if things
like banking apps budgeting software and
online accounting tools are important to
you be sure to inquire about the
technological support they offer even
though these advantages come from big
banks huge size in their ads they often
go out of their way to portray
themselves as homey familiar even rustic
it's as if they're saying little
organizations are more trustworthy
so if you find these commercials
persuasive maybe you should check out
the smaller organizations in your
neighborhood and that's our two cents
[Music]